so thank you for you all being here for
my talk welcome to my talk about xai
meets natural language processing
um so this talk will be about
explainable ai about different options
to
use explainable ai techniques to natural
language processing problems
um just a quick remark beforehand i'm in
the middle of my work about this topic
so
i cannot guarantee you any completeness
i'm still like trying things out i'm
doing research so if you have any
additions or remarks for me any tips
i would be also be grateful and we can
maybe have a chat after the talk
so maybe
before i start some words about me i'm
larissa i'm
from heidelberg i studied politics and
data science in mannheim before work
starting to work as a data scientist in
heidelberg at cervante
in my spare time i like to do sports
play ultimate frisbee play round net and
read a lot of science fiction so if you
want to
chat about that that's also pretty fine
um
and now i'm working a lot with business
processes and the automation of business
processes um especially like in the nlp
in the natural language processing area
so
recently
i was involved in a customer project and
that made me think about explainability
um in
the terms of nlp so how to explain um
predictions made with nlp models and m
systems
so
maybe you've heard about that term
explainable ai maybe you haven't
i first want to
talk briefly about what it is
so
explainable ai are
processes and methods to
understand your ai systems better so the
goal is to increase the accuracy of your
model because when you understand your
ai systems better you can for example
discover
biases i don't know if you
were at the talk yesterday by sonam and
she really explained really good um how
you can see the the biases in your data
and in your ai system by yeah looking
into the black box
another goal is to increase
yeah the fairness of your systems so it
also is connected to to
yeah the biases
and to have better outcomes of your
predictions
also when looking into the future it
might be like a legal requirement to for
your ai systems to be explainable um
it's not
i think it's not officially yet but
there are tendencies for for example
users that they can request why
for example they were put in a certain
category so
yeah you might want to think about this
also in the legislation way
um
right now i'm just talking about ai
systems and why is that
ai system involves the whole process
that you see here so from
the data selection the data collection
and the setup which model you're using
which parameters you use um
over feature engineering the structure
um the model that you use and the
decisions it makes
this is all connected to the
yeah to the ai system but i think the
first four parts they are just quite
visible i mean you can present your data
you can visualize it you can
explain the features that you engineered
maybe it's a little bit more complex but
it's like it's a tangible topic and you
can explain it
while models and decisions
they are more a black box um you cannot
easily plot a model and explain why it
has
why it comes to certain predictions or
not
so um yeah in the next couple of minutes
i want to focus on the last two steps so
i'm
i won't talk about how to visualize your
data but i want to keep you in mind that
this is also important and it's also
part of explainability when you start
thinking about that term
um why even bother about explainability
i already
gave some
some ideas about that
there are a lot of reasons why
explainability is important um it's not
only for the end users who want to know
why certain predictions are made it's
also for us as technical staff to know
how our models behave to maybe
make them better to improve the outcomes
but also depending on your role for for
example
if you're a manager and you have to
um
yeah you have to to speak about why
you're using ai and why you're using a
certain model and a certain system it's
always good to know what's happening
under the hood and what yeah how the
decisions are made
this is especially
important to think about explainability
in nlp because
the models or the ai systems they solve
tasks with text and text is closely
connected to human beings
when you have nlp models
most of the time they work closely
together with
human co-workers and they need to trust
and they need to understand the
predictions of the model
so especially in nlp it's important
to think about explainability
and one last remark explainability is
also closely connected to ai ethics
there are a lot of great videos a lot of
great talks about that topic it's also
important to see those two topics
together but when i start talking about
that we will probably be a little bit
over time
so
i want to present you some approaches
some options how to deal with
explainability in nlp projects
you can roughly
divide the the approaches into
m4 sections so on the one hand you have
model agnostic and model specific
approaches
model agnostic approaches are
independent of the model
that you're using so
it's a yeah
really good point if you have a setup
you have already
introduced explainability
you can just easily switch the model
behind it and leave your setup as it is
because it's model agnostic you can just
yeah keep working with your explainable
setup and maybe improve the model don't
think about oh i need to keep with the
decision tree because i already built my
whole system on the values of this of
the decision tree
um and then on the other hand you have
the decision between global and local
explainability
where
global explains the impact for the whole
data set and local
explains an impact only for one
prediction so you have here for example
two
the the image of the decision tree
when you have global explainability you
take the whole decision tree into
accounts or you can explain
each prediction that is made from that
tree
and on the right hand side you have only
one path
of the decision tree so
you can use this explainability only to
explain this single prediction that was
made
this is like the
distinction between global and local
explainability
so
yeah based on the
experience i made in this customer
project with
explainability and the different
approaches
that
we tried i want to just show you those
approaches and maybe give some some
feeling
if this approach could fit also for your
um for your kind of problems
so um
the first idea i don't know if you ever
thought about it but you can use human
annotations
you can if you have a data set and it
gets labeled by humans you can just ask
them and include
reasons why they edit the label
it's i think it's really cool if you
have the chance to do that and you get
you can use then the reason as a
another label and let it be predicted by
your model
but i mean in the end it's not
explainability how the model came to the
conclusion that this label is right but
what the model thinks that the human
co-worker thought why this label was
right but i just think it's a it's a
cool idea um
it's a cool way to think about
explainability and if you know that
option it also makes you think about
which kind of explainability do i want
in my
in my process in my ai system
um
another option is to use feature
importances and model structures that
you just have from your model um so for
example there is a
i don't know if you're familiar with
bird there are also a lot of great talks
about that topic and it's a very common
nlp model type
um and it it's trained in different
layers and you can use
the layers
and send data through it and
yeah observe the the attention of those
of those layers to certain words so for
example and this is the third
layer of a bird model
and
the color of
the
words indicate how much you can change
the word without changing the sentence
so a very dark color means
there is only a little
yeah space you can move the word a
lighter color is you can just change the
word and the sentence would
keep its meaning so for example if you
would change
bird
it would change the meaning of the
sentence quite a lot but for example two
or has like those
auxiliary verbs or auxiliary um words
they are not that important
so you can just use the structure that
is already there to get a glimpse on how
your model
comes to conclusions
but it depends i mean if you're not
using bird or if you're not using a
model that allows you to do this this is
not the right option for you
then
third i mean you could always use
understandable models
um this is
quite difficult i think for nlp topics
but i don't know if you ever seen nlp
data i mean you have text most often you
transform text into
numbers into word embeddings into
vectors
so it's really difficult you can train
decision trees
on nlp data on embeddings but
in the end
even you even though you can understand
the model and the tree structure you it
wouldn't help you i mean
you then see okay the third
value in my vector has a high impact so
okay but what that does that mean
um
[Music]
but i don't know
it could be that you have nlp data that
it's really good for decision trees it's
an option you can try or also for
regression or other interpretable
or understandable models it really
depends on your data if this will work
another option
um
are lime shep and li5
i just heard that yesterday there was a
great talk about lime also so
i won't go
into too much detail here so maybe just
um then ask the expert about that but um
yeah in short
lime and shab they work with
correlations
so you
have your model which is a black box and
it does not depend on which model
it is used so it's a model agnostic
approach
you use this black box and you
put data through it you take your data
you permutate your
data points
and feed it into your model observe the
prediction and then correlate how the
permutation and the
change prediction
correlates
i think it's really cool approach
um on the top you see
an example how this works with images so
you have an image you have the
prediction this is a frog
and then you
mask or you permutate
single parts of the picture and you
observe how the prediction changes
so in this case
um the first picture
it still has like
85 to be a frog and then you just take
those results put it into an
understandable
model into a explainable model
and
yeah observe how the
weights
behave and we can now see in this frog
example that the face is a really
important indicator for this model that
the picture shows a frog
i think that's really cool the
problem is that this that lime in this
case only works for local um
explainability and so you can all you
can just like explain for this single
example for this picture
um
the the importance of the face to be
yeah important
and then there's um there are sharp
values
um
sharp values they can be local but also
used for global explainability
and
you can see here example with text so
sharp values
show how much single elements for
example in a sentence contribute to the
overall prediction
um so you can imagine it just like a
football team each player has his or her
own
um yeah impact on the game and the
outcome is like the the team performance
the differences between lyme and shep i
have a little example
i want to explain now so
imagine you have a
classification if a youtube comment is
spam or no spam
in this case you have the
data point for christmas song visit my
channel
i think it's spam
then
um to to try out or to test your model
you take this sentence you you just
separate it into words into tokens
and then you mask
the tokens so for example when there is
a one
and the word is there when there's a
zero the word is masked so taken out
and you have um the probability
um
that the model
says okay this is still spam or this is
no spam so for example
the third and the fourth option
where just
four visit my channel is still with a
high probability it's still
spam
and then you have the differences
between lyme and shep and this is in the
weighting of this probability
in their calculations so lyme is just
waiting
the probability with how close is my
permutation to the original sentence
and for shabbit is
how
how many
coalitions do i have oh i see i have a
typo there so how many coalitions do i
find have i have do i have a high amount
of ones or a high amount of zeros
because the theory is
you can single out
single impacts so if i have for example
everything masked except for channel
i still have a high probability and this
is just quite cool because i see that
the word channel has a high probability
for my model to classify something as
bam and this is also very high weighted
by sharp
and this is also why you can use shap
for global explainability and not just
only for local
then there is li5
li5 i don't know
if you knew but it stands for x-plane
like m5 and i think
um it's just
it's just also a cool method to use it
yeah kind of works in a similar way it
shows the contribution a word has
or yeah a word has to a certain
prediction
and
it's nice that it works out of the box
for the scikit-learn pipelines so you
can it's not completely model agnostic
but you can use it for a different
circuit learn
algorithms and it also takes the
pre-processing into account
so
it really works well
if you have the the setup that
it's required here
now my
last
approach that i want to present
are graphical representations
um i think they are really good
especially for explaining what
nlp is and how nlp works
you can use for example if you have word
embeddings
word vectors into use you can use
for example a dimensional reduction
to
bring your word vectors into a
two-dimensional shape
um and then you can just see where the
points are located on your data grid
example i don't know if you know this
one is
whispered it's a q a
website so you can ask a bird model a
question
and the question gets answered and you
can observe how the
layers
move or push the
points on this grid around so how the
answers how the answer gets
shaped by the different layers and i
think it's really cool to visualize how
this model works
but on the other hand i mean you have
always a dimensional reduction you come
from
300 400 dimensions and you reduce it to
two dimensions i mean some information
gets lost there
but i really think
it's a cool approach and it's it's
really
tangible to to see okay i have
words that are closely connected
and i have differences between others
so
these were my five
approaches that i wanted to show you
today
i also
included a
little table where you have maybe some
my personal evaluation and
there are also great articles in the web
that also do similar things
um
in case you want to keep those links i
will upload the slides and my github so
you can you don't have to to manually
type them in now
[Music]
just to to sum everything up what are
difficulties for nlp models um
you have the high amount of dimensions
and that is clearly a difficulty
you have
a high variability in models and
representations it's not like numerical
data which you can just like show in
numerical way
you
have a bag of words you have maybe a
skip gram model you have
biograms you have
embeddings word vectors so it really
depends on your use case what
explainability you can use
what i find pretty difficult is a set of
tokens is not equal to variables
so a set of tokens is more like image
data because you have always to keep the
context into account
and it's not just like
numbers that appear
together
then you have this switch from local to
global
explainability which i think it's also
um the transfer is also quite difficult
and um
because of the size and the dimension
and the complexity of word vectors it's
also too difficult it's also difficult
to show is
show this um on in a graphical way i
mean for numbers you can just plot plot
them you can have a histogram you can
have
curves but for um
for
word vectors for example i mean you can
print them out but then you have a
dictionary size print out and nobody
knows what to do with it
and the last difficulty i see here and
this was especially in my customer
project important
even absent words are important
so if for example in a comment
you have a word that is not used it's
also it's just important for the
prediction that some words are not used
and how do you show this
on a grid i mean you don't have the data
point there for this word
um how do you show this in a in a table
where you have the impacts you have a
lot of words that are not there but also
have an impact
um so this is this was one
one point that i found pretty difficult
to explain and also to show
so just a quick wrap-up about the
customer project i won't go into detail
here
just
this was how we explained it to the
customer we had
text training data
we had we made some feature engineering
so we did a word complexity measurements
sentence length
word reliability measurements and then
we had embeddings so in this case
a custom tf-idf
embedded mechanism
and we combined it into a model
and in the end we had a poc dashboard
where the customer could see for a
single prediction
how this prediction
yeah was was done so we had on the top
like the the binary
prediction in class r or class b
and then
we had
aggregation of
aggregation of sharp values depending on
the location in the text so we knew okay
our text is structured in a certain way
we have four different paragraphs and we
can just aggregate the shape values
within the paragraphs and this made it
very tangible for the customer because
they could see okay the paragraph
four had a lot had a big impact into
this prediction
and then we just had the
engineered features also as shap values
separated from the normal tf idf
and to wrap everything up
my lessons learned from this project you
have to really think about how to
explain the explainability so it's not
enough to just calculate the values
you have to explain to the customer what
these values mean and this is
i think a greater challenge than just
calculate them
how do you present it how do you
make it understandable
also the absence of words how do you
display them
do you even talk about it i mean do you
want to open that
that box and to explain how these models
work
um
you have to find a fitting
representation you have to to include
help texts to for the customer or for
the user to understand it and you really
have to reduce complexity to the topic
that the user really wants to know about
this prediction
so
i also included some of the articles
that i used for this presentation also
for research there are really great
great articles out there just
have a look at them
and
if you
want to keep in contact
you can always chat with me on twitter
or on linkedin and
you find the slides on github so
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you for your amazing talk that was
so interesting i'm pretty new on that
topic and i feel like i've just learned
a lot um we have a lot of questions
so i guess i was not alone in enjoying
this um and we probably won't get
through them all but hopefully you don't
mind folks to
come up to you afterwards yes of course
um but let's try address some of the top
voted ones so elena is asking
the examples you showed are all document
classification problems
have you explored the approaches for
other nlp tasks i.e translation named
entity recognition
so
for translation i unfortunately have no
experience um for
ner i think you can just
use also the model agnostic approaches
because
you
just take
the model as a black box and wrap the
explainer around and it doesn't really
like matter what's inside so i think you
can just use the approaches and try try
it out
so maybe elena who asked the question
can also try that out
and let us know
okay so i didn't get the difference
between local and global could you um
please explain it to me like i'm five
yes i can try
so
um imagine you have a lot of people like
you see here in this picture you have a
group of people
and you want to
you have a model that
specifies that that predicts the first
letter of your name
and when you have global explainability
you can just explain the prediction from
your model for each of
the people in your
in your group when you have a local
explainability you have to pick one of
them out and you can explain why the
model predicted
a name with an a at the beginning but
you don't know about the others so this
is just a difference and global
explainability usually is a lot more
costly so you have to think about do i
really need data from all of the data
points
or is it enough that i can just explain
single predictions and yeah do not need
information about the whole data set
it's a great explanation i would say
hopefully it also answered the person
that asked it maybe maybe they can come
find you maybe five years was not the
a smart five-year-old
if you ask your human annotators for
their label explanations
how can you encode that data and use it
within the er ex
x-a-i algorithm
so you can for example i don't know i
come from the social sciences and when
we
label text or when we um here have have
a data set we in the beginning we create
a rule set how to
label data and you could do just the
same so you could for example have a set
of categories like 10 categories and the
human annotator could select one of them
as a reason for example so you have a
fixed set of options and then you could
use it as a label to pre-predict it
or they can just maybe then they also
can single out words that they used for
their labels so for example in a in the
spam
example you can just highlight the
channel as a important word and you can
just use this later on
yeah it's very interesting suggestions
i'm okay so let's say we find out that
channel is important for classifying
something as you mentioned
as spam
to what extent is that a fundamental
explanation of the model
i mean it's um
[Music]
it's not an explanation like how the
model
did this
because this is just uh i mean the model
is probably a mathematical construct and
you could also just print the some of
the weights in your neural net but this
won't help you as a human to understand
and if you have
[Music]
the importance of the word it's always a
trade-off between what gives the model
you as information and what does a human
need a human being need to understand it
so
i think most of us need some
some text some context to understand
values and not just can see okay i have
here a vector of 300
um
values and now i see okay this one was
the most important one so you always
need
there's always a trade-off between
accuracy of the the model prediction or
the explanation of the model prediction
and the understandability for a human
being
yeah great answer thank you
um okay
can you use the graphical methods on the
whole texts somehow
not only word vectors
i mean there are word clouds but i
i'm not a great fan of word clouds um
i'm not sure
what this question is referring to i
mean
usually you can count words
and just have a histogram
maybe
i'm not the right person to ask maybe we
can ask a linguist i mean they have
great
ways to visualize
text in
in their yeah in their text form not in
a word vector form but just have a look
at that i think they have they have
great ideas there
thank you again
i'm okay so we're running a bit over so
i'm not going to go through the rest of
the questions but would really invite
you to reach out to larissa and you
already shared your information on how
folks can do so if they can't find you
in the conference today
just one last one it's not a question
but i wanted to read it out anyway which
was great talk and 100 agree
[Applause]
you